good afternoon
everybody virtually and welcome to this
uh
press conference on the digital decade
package we are pleased to have mcgregor
executive vice president for europe fit
for the digital age good afternoon
and uh commissioner market
our press conference follows of course
the state of the union address of
the president on wednesday where she
announced the proposal on high
performance computing
and recommendation on connectivity both
were adopted today
we have issued press materials just
published now
press release a memo and a fact sheet on
each of the two initiatives and without
further ado give the floor to
secretary vice president well thank you
very much
uh today as just said uh we present to
you two proposals
to advance our digital agenda
the first proposal is a new regulation
for the european
high performance computing joint
undertaking
and the second proposal is a
recommendation for member states
to boost investment in connectivity
infrastructure
high performance or super super
computers they are really important
uh for our future uh they support the
health
sector uh by for instance creating what
you could call
a digital human twin
like this we can stimulate trillions
of processes and molecule molecules of
the human body
to advance treatments tackle diseases
or viruses and improve diagnostics
we can use supercomputers to
investigate options and designs of
efficient
earth system modeling um
what we call sort of the planet earth
twin
uh that will inform but also advance
uh policy making and it will help us to
find solutions
uh when we're fighting a climate change
supercomputers they can support
businesses to innovate
to test and to scale up much beyond what
we have
uh today in october uh
2018 we put together with
member states and and private
contributors
1.5 billion euros uh to the first
joint in undertaking on high performance
uh computing
now we want uh to scale up and to
continue
uh this ambition in the next
multi-annual financial framework
with a further total of eight billion
euros
to be invested in this digital capacity
connectivity obvious is the backbone for
digital solutions
we want to speed up the investment in
high-speed
internet for businesses public services
and for citizens as such it is
uh needed to accelerate
our efforts when it comes to 5g
deployment
due to covets some of the auctions when
it comes to frequencies for 5d
they were delayed but we should not
slow down these investments so we call
on member states to develop a toolbox
with best practices as to how to invest
in connectivity
these are just two tangible examples as
to how we can advance
our digital
agenda because if not
well then we remain in the situation
we're in now
and even though we have seen how
connectivity helped us during the
lockdown
i also think a lot of people and
businesses realize
that we have to push further on all
changes
they need a driver and they need a
purpose
to happen and for the coming decade
we need to have these drivers very clear
in our mind
the most fundamental driver is to serve
the people
a digital transformation that includes a
accountable
democratic and fair economy will help us
to do better i think we all agree
that the digital transformation had
brought many advances
to our society access to innovative
and convenient services for citizens
new ways for companies to reach their
consumers
their customers but in that respect
in spite of all the progress made it is
very important
uh that we do not let a few
literally a handful of privately owned
companies
define the rules of the game for the
marketplaces
that they have created if done so in an
unfair manner
with size comes responsibility
resize also comes economic power for
some companies
to dominate markets in ways that
threatens fair competition
so in the coming december we will
table the digital services act who will
propose
a new competition tool and the aim of
those proposals
is to ensure a fully functioning and
competitive single market
for digital uh services based
on european values
for each and every one of us i think
that
the things that happen close to home is
the one that matters
the most uh solution that ease our lives
well they also change
our behavior for instance to be able to
do digital
tax declarations instead of having to
file on paper
connected cashiers that directly
transmit data to the tax authority
to prevent tax evasion but
also to prevent sort of the long
processing on paper
by the end of the year it could be
electronic
prescriptions that allows you to pick up
necessary
medicines at every pharmacy that you
pass
all of this is useful no matter where
you are in europe
and we want to enable the access to
public
private and cross-border services
and to use these in a seamless manner
and in a data secure way of course it's
very important that we can identify
ourselves so we will soon propose
a secure european e-identity
and this will not only enable us to
identify ourselves
it will also enable us to get better
control of our data
i think it's a thing where everyone has
a worry if you get it right
on a daily basis if we are fully in
control
just a couple of examples uh
during covet uh 19 greece set up within
24 hours
a special number where requests for
uh permission for special outings were
sent by
sms and then the author
authorization was sent back uh to the
mobile
so that everyone they knew that on their
phone they had the necessary permits
when they were going out during lockdown
this very simple idea empowered citizens
and created a trust in digital services
that the government have launched now
over the last couple of months
and the public sector as illustrated
with this example
can be a better enabler of change
latvia have introduced a large-scale
communication and training programs
to enable people to get better digital
skills
when they use digital services uh that
is the change that benefit every citizen
but also every business
so in order to create this drive we
propose to invest
20 percent of the recovery and and
resilience facility
in digital transformation uh this target
target will focus mines so that we
incorporate
in our recovery that we can leapfrog to
a better use of digital technologies
there's a lot of money to spends in the
recovery fund
and these targets will help us spend
them
wisely because here we can also make
sure that the public spending
will crowd in private investment and
stimulate
innovation and competition throughout
europe a combination
of public and private investment is
necessary
to achieve not only the digital
transformation that we want
but also the recovery uh that we want
uh the target of 20 uh that is
ambitious uh as it's we have
challenges ahead of us uh that are huge
and we will work very closely with
member states
to enable how this can be integrated in
recovery plans
but also how to to tack the different
investments to make sure that we
actually do reach
our targets cross-border
and multi-country projects of course
they are
close to our heart and they should be
very important in this context
the last but not least we hope that many
member states will invest in digital
skills today
only just above
sixty percent uh have the necessary
basic
uh skills today so forty percent
uh remaining uh and if we want everyone
to be able to benefit
of course this is a very important very
fundamental
investment and here we have a tool the
recovery and resilience
plans they will help us to do this
it may seem as as this is long overdue
but if you look at member states who've
been pushing forward
you see the benefits that comes also
with a digital of recovery
and today i think we have taken two very
tangible
uh and very concrete steps also to
enhance
the best use of digital technologies
thank you very much my great and uh
thank you all for being with us this
afternoon
um francie
foreign
branch
foreign
capacity
foreign
foreign
continued
uh
um
[Music]
[Music]
is
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much uh secret vice
president with now time for your
questions please piece of kind and state
your name and the name of the media
you're working for the first one in
the list to raise the center is van
someone on politico
um hello can you hear me yes we can hear
you
yeah great um vincent from politico
speaking
um so the commission today as you said
is releasing recommendations to boost
5g rollout but citizens and petitions
across europe
notably including in france have
misgivings about the technology
what's your message for these people
the the point of of technology is not to
have it for its own sake
the point of technology is is to say
well what can we do better
i think all over europe you find
citizens who say oh but
but promises were not kept
of a world-class health services
of the best possible education of ease
of getting from a to b
in traffic could we have that please
and i think technology can can help us
to do what we want to do
to make sure that everyone can get you
know proper diagnostics can get their
test results very fast
uh that students can get access to
world-class education that they may not
otherwise be able to access
that we can have an ease of of traveling
uh
that we would otherwise not be able to
have because we can combine different
modes of traveling
and on that note of course also that's
uh greening of our economy will be
enabled by technology
that's of course entails as uh just
mentioned
that we break uh bring down the use of
electricity
uh in for instance our cloud services
but that we can do
and in that europe can be a leader and
produce more jobs and more innovation
that we would otherwise be able to do
and and i think that is the important
thing to say well
technology is an enabler it's not an end
in itself
and and we have a firm belief uh that a
proper use of technology will bring
better services
but also jobs uh in our economy and i
think that is the main
the main idea here that developing a
society
is about people but to do what we want
to do we need technology
next person
hello this is naomi o'leary from the
irish times
i have a question for commissioner
vestiger
um could you please tell us commissioner
whether
you want to appeal the july ruling
on the apple tax case thank you
later today after this press conference
i don't know what i would like to reply
nevertheless no but
but now that i'm here i'd be more than
happy to to reply we haven't taken that
decision yet
as the commission always uh do
we wait until we are closer to the
deadline of uh
of the of the appeal uh question and
then of course i'll be happy to come
back to that
thanks thanks johannes and thank you to
our esteemed commissioners for joining
us here today congratulations on the
launch
of the digital decade package today as
well
i just had a quick question on
connectivity so
one of the goals one of the commission
goals in connectivity previously
was to launch 5g services in all eu
member states by the end of 2020
will that target now be met and if not
has another target for deployment been
identified
and more generally now what's your take
on the deployment of 5g
across european union member states and
is there the risk
of having a very fractured market in
this field
thank you
well come the lady um
um
[Music]
foreign
come on yes good afternoon vice
president
thank you for taking my question it's a
question for vice president this tiger
if i may
we are talking about connectivity high
and
high speed connectivity and in italy
an important operation was announced
between
team and the casa de positive
restitution they agreed to form a new
company
for a unique network in italy
but according to what we read a team
would have the majority
we've read yesterday that on bloomberg
that the competition the digicomp
would be i mean not very happy about
this structure i mean
the problem seems to be the majority
envisage for team
i know that the operation has not yet
been notified
to the commission but i wonder if you
have
anything to say about this because it is
a highly sensitive topic in italy and
also quite important for the future of
the
high-speed network thank you
yes i mean of course you would prefer to
take questions related to today's topic
it's it's
kind of related and i guess we're
already in touch with the spp on this
question but of course
vice president well i i read the papers
uh
too uh i don't always recognize uh what
i
i read in the papers uh on rare
occasions of course only
as you say uh the exact deal whatever
that may turn out to be
is not notified to us so obviously
there are no details to to discuss when
it's notified it's an open case and as
you know then i will not discuss it
either so you have sort of a catch-22
there
the thing that i can say is that in
general
so with no direct comment uh to the
to the the companies in question here uh
is that one can imagine that you have a
a nationwide
wholesaler that is that is
definitely imaginable the question is of
course is that an independent wholesaler
or would a wholesaler also have specific
uh
ties uh vertically to retailers
that would be an important competition
assessment
and that would be sort of our general
approach no matter what country
it would be concerned with
thank you very much i don't see any
further questions in the system unless
someone is decided at the last minute
yes follow up
then this should be hi sorry me again um
just because um so the the
the question i asked before um i'd like
to direct to commissioner breton
um just because uh france has become a
particular flash point
um for these um issues around 5g
with many politicians and mayors
expressing their misgivings around it
thank you
[Music]
technology
technology
um
uh
foreign i'd like to take one last
question of a hungarian colleague
kathleen haimai who
just raised her hand katharine
nothing
please speak do you hear me yes do you
hear me now
yes yes yes thank you very much johannes
this is also an
off topic question to the executive vice
president
and touches upon the hungarian media
market
there are several complaints submitted
to the commission on the alleged
distortion of competition in the
hungarian media market
and one of the complaints was filed on
the alleged
excessive funding of public broadcast
media in hungary
it was submitted in 2016
and the investigation is still ongoing
so could you tell us executive vice
president
please why it takes four or even more
years
to come up with a result one would think
this is a small and not a very
complicated
media market thank you very much
it's also a question we have discussed
in the press room already at in length
but of course
i don't want to blame the potential
answer you would like to give for them
well but you did that very effectively
i'd say
to say that it has been discussed
intensively before
no i understand completely the the
impatience
uh and it may seem straightforward
but things are never straightforward
when you have issues of
support uh the media landscape media
plurality
issues um i wish uh
that we had finalized uh our
investigation and our thoughts uh so far
but but we haven't
uh and of course we will continue uh to
look into it uh because we have a
complaint and obviously we take
our complaints seriously this uh
brings us now to the end of our press
conference thank you very much executive
foreign
um i refer again to our press materials
and let me wish you
and all of us actually a nice afternoon
and a good weekend
yes
you